hello and welcome to a special edition
of the daily climate show on sky news
bangladesh climate front line on today's
programme
we meet those forced from their homes
because of the impact of climate change
in one of the world's most
environmentally vulnerable
countries a global issue
ahead of the cop 26 climate summit in
glasgow
bangladesh's foreign minister tells sky
news the country needs
more help from other governments
and the floating gardens helping farmers
grow crops
on flooded lands
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and today we have a special
edition of the programme
all about one of the countries most at
risk from our changing environment
bangladesh with a population of over 163
million people
is facing a climate emergency the
country
is uniquely vulnerable to the powerful
and unpredictable impacts of climate
change
due to its low elevation dense
population
and weak infrastructure cyclones
frequently hit the country
many like last year's cyclone and fan
form in the bay of bengal
before making landfall in bangladesh and
the country also
experiences extremely heavy rainfall
during monsoon season at least a quarter
of bangladesh
can end up submerged last year alone
more than
4 million people were displaced by
intense flooding which continues to
devastate villages
and farmland all of these factors are
worsening an already dire situation
of rural poverty in the country and it's
a problem that's growing at an alarming
rate by 2050 it's estimated
that sea levels around the country could
rise by 50 centimeters
now that would mean bangladesh losing
approximately 11
of its land with homes schools and in
some cases entire villages being lost
many have no choice but to migrate to
dakar
they join up to 2 000 people who make
the journey into the capital every day
searching for better living conditions
and new opportunities
and it's a city already struggling to
cope with the growing population
of more than 21 million people sky's
katerina vittotsi has been to the islam
of kalyan poor in dakar
where climate displaced people are now
trapped in unsafe homes and in a cycle
of debt and poverty
in kalyan slum there are no road names
just alleyway numbers
it's dark dirty and a side of climate
change you don't expect
and rarely see
every year climate change is forcing
half a million bangladeshis from their
rural homes
most end up in dakar city slums
where space is running out salaam
alaikum
no johan begum arrived last year from
the coast
with her family she tells us they had a
small
farm but now they're renting a two-room
shack
with no windows and barely enough room
to move
yes
bangladesh is on the climate change
front line
it's geographically vulnerable to rising
sea levels and stronger cyclones
most climate migrants were fishermen or
farmers
they've seen their homes livelihoods
even their land
disappeared
until then they're stuck in a place
where landlords
some with political connections charge
high prices for unsafe homes
electricity is connected illegally
sewers flood when it rains
[Music]
is
but what use is a dustpan against
monsoon rain
and a drain put in to help does the
reverse
that brings the water but that's
bringing the water in you want the water
to go the other way
yes and the water is dirty he says it
smells
dhaka is now the most crowded city in
the world on the verge of yet another
strict covert 19 lockdown
thousands of migrant workers have
escaped for their rural homes
climate change migrants don't have that
option
foreign
over the last 20 years bangladesh has
lifted millions of people
out of poverty
at the capitals main port you can see
the trade and industry that has expanded
the economy
grown the middle class but also drawn
people to a city
that now can't cope daca is crumbling
taka is crumbling under under people
coming here and do you think this is the
side of climate change that people just
don't
see and don't realize exists yeah they
don't connect
uh this reality with climate change
because
because they think it's coastal areas
this is uh this is something that's
gonna happen in the future
but this is dystopia i mean this is
happening in real time
and i think the world doesn't know
enough about it but people here
can't just wait she understand english
are you understanding yes
she read in class in one alleyway we
meet tanya akhtar who's 18.
[Music]
her family moved here to escape rising
sea levels
she hopes this small school run on the
family bed
can somehow do something i
teaches them english bengali
math they are
they doesn't speak english
i am little i'm little but i try my best
to teach them
this is minara this is tanya's mother
and she wanted to tell us how proud she
felt of her daughter
for doing this teaching but she wanted
to try and say it in english so
tandy is doing a little bit of impromptu
teaching as well
so that she can say on camera of how
proud she is of her daughter
do you want do you want to say it
tell us how you feel about your daughter
i feel proud
i feel proud proud
to my daughters to my daughter
in climate change there are tipping
points a moment from where
there is no return people here want to
go
back home but to what for many
this is now their future
category sky news dakar
and you can read more about dakar and
bangladesh's climate migrants as well as
the day's other climate news on our
website
just head to sky news dot com slash
climate
with the impact of climate migration in
dakar clear katherine vatosi spoke to
bangladesh's foreign minister
about what could be done to help address
the problem
this is happening every day so many
people
go to the dhaka city minimum half a
million people every year
and currently we can accommodate in our
slums
but how long if the 30-40 million they
will try to move to the other country
where will they go it will be security
problem for the whole world
do you think the biggest polluters who
have made
money from the industrial revolution
they should be
coming voluntarily with financial
assistance of course
the climate issue is a global issue and
it cannot be resolved by
one country or two country alone there
must be
a strong commitment so we expect other
countries should come forward
particularly those who really abuse and
misuse
the resources of the planet pandemic
came
we are having lot of difficulties a lot
of difficulties
but climate energy climatic changes will
be much
much worse than the spending we must
take action action for mitigation
action for adaptation extend action for
you know arranging financing we have to
do it
let's take a look now at some of the
other climate news from bangladesh
and the country will host the first
virtual v20 financial summit on climate
vulnerabilities in july
heads of state from climate vulnerable
forum countries and v20 finance
ministers will attend
along with speakers including the uk's
chancellor rishi sunak
the group hopes to agree on a series of
financial and economic measures to help
countries become
more climate resilient the uk government
says it's committed to helping poorer
countries like bangladesh with the costs
of climate change
g7 leaders renewed an agreement made in
2009 to raise a hundred billion dollars
a year in climate finance to developing
nations
earlier i spoke to climate change
minister anne-marie trevelyan about how
the uk
is contributing we've ring-fenced uh uh
our doubling of our climate change
commitment to 11.6 billion
uh because we know that that's an
absolutely critical
uh part of the support that we put into
the international pot but there is much
further to go
uh without doubt anna and actually
getting uh all those
uh developed countries who uh can be
part of the donor community to go
further
uh in the climate finance space is a
really important challenge for us as
a cop president
and bangladesh has cancelled plans to
build 10 coal power stations following
pressure from activists to use more
renewable energy
in 2019 99.3 of the country's energy
came from fossil fuels the government
has confirmed only eight of the original
18 plants will now go ahead
and the rest will be replaced with
renewable energy sources
and in this week's episode of climate
cast i'll be speaking to our
correspondent katarina vittotsi about
her time filming in bangladesh
and we hear from the country's new
climate envoy
that'll be out from friday wherever you
normally get your podcast from
well as more people are forced from
their homes and suffer the impact
of our changing climate there are groups
in bangladesh working to protect the
environment
and defend the rights of communities
dependent on nature
and natural resources one of those is
the bangladesh environmental lawyers
association
and reswan hassan is their chief
executive and joins me now
welcome to you tell us why is
environmental justice work
so important in bangladesh
thank you very much it is very important
for bangladesh because bangladesh
is a creation of the rivers it is the
largest delta of the world
a majority of the people in bangladesh
depend on natural resource bases for
their living and livelihood
for example agriculture employs most of
the people here in bangladesh
and we get 24 percent of our gdp from
agriculture we are the second largest
sweetwater fishery of the world
we have the world's largest mangrove
forest in bangladesh
we have the world's largest unbroken
sea beach here in bangladesh so the
coastal community the fishery community
the
farmers committee does they solely
depend on the
natural resource bases and that is why i
would say that
this is very important for bangladesh
and if this natural resource bases
is disturbed is polluted is contaminated
due to the fears that we are having from
climatic change
that will actually disrupt uh people's
life in a major way
well yes and your work focuses on local
communities so give us an idea of
the kind of environmental issues that
they're facing and how you might be able
to help them
we are an association of lawyers so we
give people legal assistance people
come to us uh with different kinds kinds
of um
grievances they come to us when their
reavers are
polluted by industries when their rivers
are being used as a mining sector
and there are sand extraction and stone
extraction
they come to us when the government
arbitrarily imposes
development scheme on them in the name
of coal-based power plant
in the name of private economic zone
they come to us
when they're in hazardous occupation
like the shipbreaking so they want
protection against the occupational
hazards and we can see that
a good number of people are now coming
to us communities are coming to us to
protect their forests
which is uh being subjected to you know
destruction due to
different development interventions by
the government people are
also increasingly coming to us to get
legal protection against increasing
natural disasters
rizwana hassan thank you so much
thank you although bangladesh is one of
the countries most affected by climate
change there are stories of hope
solutions and adaptation too farmers in
the country's lowlands are bringing back
a traditional agricultural method
by sowing their crops on rafts made of
water hyacinth plants
the floating gardens allowed them to
continue growing vegetables like okra
and spinach
during the monsoon season and it's hoped
the method could be transferred to other
areas of the world
facing similar issues with flooding well
that's it for this
special edition of the daily climate
show coming up tomorrow
how insects could be the key to making
animal feed
more environmentally friendly thanks for
watching see you then
you